c'est un joli défi et des heures de
travail pour lui lui c'est un jeune
Blaisois passionné par le jeu Minecraft
un jeu de construction et d'exploration
que 175 millions de personnes dans le
monde ont l'habitude d'explorer il a
reconstitué virtuellement la place Jean
Jaurès de Tours et le centre ville de
Blois un travail minutieux salué déjà
sur les réseaux découvertes avec Hélène
chapelet
la place Jean Jaurès à Tours
reconstituée au sein de l'univers
cubique de Minecraft son hôtel de ville
et son palais de justice ce travail on
le doit un jeune Blaisois dans sa
chambre à sellette dès qu'il a un peu de
temps devant lui Valentin s'acharne a
reproduire l'architecture des centres
villes de tours et de Blois des heures
et des heures de travail et
d'observation pour essayer d'être le
plus fidèle possible à la réalité
la taille des routes les ponts les
lampes les trottoirs les
morceaux de banc les arbres tous les
bâtiments tous c'est vraiment moi qui
est la taille tout ça c'est moi qui l'ai
fait minecraft c'est juste des blocs de
couleur et il y a pas d'autres pour
faire plusieurs couleurs c'est pareil
j'ai dû les refaire en mini bloc comme
toutes les barrières-là l'arrêt de bus
c'est que des mini blocs là par exemple
j'ai dû poser des petites couches au fur
et à mesure un travail de fourmi amorcé
il y a un an déjà avec le centre ville
de Blois Valentin n'a pourtant aucune
formation c'est pour jouer avec ses amis
dans des décors qu'ils connaissent bien
qu'il s'est lancé ce défi un peu fou et
qui se poursuit parfois jusque dans ses
rêves
la première fois j'étais tellement fier
de de ce que j'avais fait sur tour
c'était tellement je trouvais ça je
pensais pas que j'étais capable de faire
un truc aussi bien et là ouais j'avais
fait un petit rêve avec j'étais dedans
pourtant c'était possible
son travail a d'ailleurs été repéré sur
Twitter et largement commenté une énorme
fierté pour cet élève en bac pro
horticole à Blois